foreign
between data scientist and software
engineer don't know which is best for
you need to know who gets better paid
this video will answer all of your
questions people often confuse that data
science and software engineering are the
same but both are different ball games
both have many differences and the role
played by a data scientist is entirely
different from that of a software
engineer after watching this video you
will come out of the confusion as we are
getting to know in detail what data
science and software engineering are so
what's in it for you firstly we are
going to discuss
what is data science after that
qualification and career paths to become
both
salary offered to a data scientist
top companies hiring them what is
software engineering after that
after that qualification and career path
to become both top companies hiring
software Engineers salary offered to
them differences between both data
scientist and software engineer
after that conclusion to the topic
first of all we will understand what
data science is
data science is the field of study that
works with massive amounts of data
utilizing relevant tools and techniques
to derive valuable data the day-to-day
work of a software engineer I repeat the
day-to-day work of a data scientist
involves collecting analyzing and
interpreting this data to help
businesses achieve their goals the role
of a data scientist is to extract raw
data and convert it into meaningful
information if we must Define data
scientists they are the people who make
value out of invaluable data or raw data
coming to stages of data science it has
mainly five stages
first is data collection or acquisition
in this stage we basically take out the
data which is to be cleaned and
processed this data may be in the form
of primary data tidy data which can be
structured or unstructured for
next is data preparation
the data collected during data
collection is processed or treated in
the states raw data cannot be processed
directly eliminating inconsistency in
data happens in this stage for example
removing blank spaces special symbols or
anything that is Irrelevant in the
column before it get handled for further
processing
next is data input
this stage is defined as the task of
coding and converting the prepared data
into computer readable data so that it
can be processed using different
software applications coming to data
processing stage this is the stage where
we use artificial intelligence
algorithms this phase requires the
assistance of a data scientist
professional who will analyze the data
properly and has expertise in AI
algorithms
and the last stage is data
interpretation
in this space we have got data which is
totally cleansed and it is to be used by
the user it can be audio video or
graphical data we have understood the
fundamentals of data science now it's
time to learn qualification to become
data scientist
basic bachelor degree is enough for a
as a data scientist you need to know
about fundamentals of mathematics
statistics after that learn machine
learning algorithms as well as AI
algorithms along with that please go
through important programming languages
for data science like Python and R
practice any of these languages
so we need computer science programming
languages
mathematics and statistics and finally
machine learning algorithms to master
data science now what is software
engineering
software engineering is the methodical
application of engineering ideas in the
development of software planning
developing creating and testing the
software application to match the
requirements are all part of software
engineering process it is one of the
most popular careers for a reason
software engineering is a comprehensive
study of engineering applied to the
design development and maintenance of
soft software Engineers use a variety of
programming languages and tools to
design test and deploy software or
solutions they are in charge of creating
and maintaining software applications
software Engineers must have the ability
to diagnose problems and solve
complicated challenges in addition to
producing code the need for
knowledgeable software Engineers is
increasing along with the need for fresh
and good software Solutions now
qualification needed for a software
engineer
firstly as a software Engineers you will
work on design development and testing
of software
for that firstly we need to learn about
data structure and algorithms after that
start to learn coding languages like C C
plus plus and Java
you will also need to learn about
testing tools if you want to become a QA
don't be scared any one of the
programming languages can be considered
no need to learn C C plus plus or Java
coming to differences between data
scientist and software engineer
role played by a data scientist a data
scientist main job is to deal with data
he is responsible for collecting
analyzing and interpreting the data here
as a data scientist you work with a team
to develop data strategy it requires a
lot of algorithms and tools we will
discuss the required tools later coming
to software engineering
a software engineer is responsible for
Designing developing testing and
deployment of software as we already
discussed about this as a software
engineer in an organization Your Role is
very important in developing a software
product a software engineer is
responsible for maintenance of the
software too now that we understood
fundamentals of data science and
software engineering it is the time to
understand differences between both of
them coming to role played by a data
scientist a data scientist main job is
to deal with data he is responsible for
collecting analyzing and interpreting
the data here as a data scientist you
work with a team to develop data
strategy it requires a lot of algorithms
and tools we will discuss about required
tool later coming to software
engineering a software engineer is
responsible for Designing development
testing and deployment of software as we
discussed about it earlier as a software
engineer in an organized Your Role is
very important in developing a software
product a software engineer is
responsible for maintenance of the
software too next is tools used in data
science data science adopts tools like
Excel tab blue gz plot to Matlab Apache
spark Etc
among all these Tableau is simple and
easy to learn for larger data sets you
may include Hadoop mapreduce Etc
went to tools used in software
engineering as a software engineer you
can go with GitHub opting IDE is based
on the programming languages choose to
work for instance if you use Java then
it's better to choose Eclipse netbeans
Etc if you are choosing C plus plus then
Visual Studio code and netbeans Etc are
preferable meaning to the programming
language as a data scientist classic
languages used at python or r
best preferred coding language for a
software developer depends on the
application commonly used ones are C C
plus plus Java python etc for web
development we use HTML CSS bootstrap
and JavaScript and for database
management we use MySQL postcode SQL to
store the data finally in testing we
have manual and automation testing but
commonly used testing is automation
testing now we will understand why we
need a data scientist every company
deals with lots and lots of data
extraction of valuable data is required
for the growth of any organization
therefore the demand of a data scientist
is very high compared to any other
position in the market around 1 million
jobs are currently available in the
world for a data scientist such as the
demand of a data scientist
so software engineer are responsible for
large project with speed and less time
so role of a software engineer in a
company cannot be negligible at all
moving on to
salary of a data scientist reward is the
result of a good work now we shall
discuss salaries that a data scientist
will get it should come as no surprise
that data scientists may add
significantly to a business at the
beginner level a data scientist makes 95
000 US dollars annually
the typical annual compensation for a
mid-level data scientist is between 130
000 and 195 000 a seasoned data
scientist typically earns between 165
000 up to 250 million dollars per year
depending on the level of experience
salary of a software engineer in U.S
entry level is 63
000 but mid-level is increasing to
eighty six thousand dollars to one
hundred thousand dollars experienced one
can get one hundred thirty thousand
dollars it can vary from company to
company but we have discussed this
average salary in this video coming to
salary offered for a data scientist in
India in India at the beginner level a
data scientist makes rupees 9 lakh forty
thousand on average per year at mid
level a data scientist will get rupees
20 lakhs per inm2 and if you are at
advanced level you will get paid an
average salary of rupees 25 lakhs
annually
coming to software engineer at beginner
level a software engineer will get
average salary as 8 lakhs per year a
mid-level experience software engineer
will be rewarded with the salary as high
as 15 lakhs per year
a senior software engineer will be
rewarded with a salary of 30 lakhs per
year this is according to indeed.com
it's time to conclude which is better
final question software engineer versus
data scientist which profession is
better both data science and software
engineering requires you to have
programming skills while data science
include statistics and machine learning
software engineer focuses more on coding
languages both career choices are in
demand and highly rewarding ultimately
it depends on your choice of Interest
although the field of data science is
soaring its importance will never
outgrow that offer software engineer
because we will need them to build
software the data scientists work on we
will always need data scientists to
analyze the data and bring new scope for
the business on which software engineer
can build software thus we reach the end
of our data science versus software
engineering video we hope you gained a
few insights regarding the topic please
make sure you subscribe to our Channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any interesting videos like this thank
you for watching keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here